I think you know China and Chinese
economy is obviously great interest to
the world to us to its profoundly of
interest to the Chinese I think that
they have a lot of tools that they have
it to continue to grow but they have to
make the right policy decisions the
challenge they have is the trade-offs
between reform and short term growth and
I'm certainly going to encourage them to
stay on a reform agenda they need to
open their markets they need to have a
level playing field so there's
market-determined prices and there can
be competition between domestic and
international goods and services and
they'd likely they'll stick with that
reform other than short-term selling us
I think I think that it they obviously
have to worry about their short-term
economic situation we all have to
balance short and long-term decisions we
make what they can't do is treat the
long-term reforms is something that I
can just put off right and they need to
be serious about it they know they need
to be serious about it they know that
their economy if it doesn't move more
towards market determine prices and and
and signals is not going to give them
the medium and long-term growth they
need something that some has their
property prices are falling and I see
some experts say that there's the
prospect that china is in a bubble
that's about to burst it will affect the
global economy is that a real danger now
look I think that you know there are a
lot of challenges the China has deal
with China has a lot of capacity to deal
with its challenges internally so I
think that the question is whether they
manage some of the things going on in
their in their economy whether it's some
price fluctuations and housing or
whether its shadow banking or state
local their local provincial finance
they have the capacity to deal with it
they need to deal with it you don't see
them in a bubble right now look I I
think that they have challenges they
have to deal with it too they focus on
jobs that are they creating enough jobs
and I think that if their stay on a path
where they're creating jobs they have
more license to do the reforms that they
need to do which is what is needed for
China to grow and for it to be a level
playing field so that us
companies can compete in China my focus
in China from a u.s. perspective is very
clear we want there to be a market that
US firms financial firms and
manufacturing firm services firms can
compete it and we bring that to the
table every time we engage with China we
also look at exchange rates exchange
rates is an extremely important issue
you know we have encouraged them are
they living up to their currency
commitment well you know they have made
some moves that are consistent with with
moving towards more market-determined
rates they widen their trading bad but
we've seen some very negative movement
in the exchange rate in recent months
one of the issues that I'm going to
bring to them is if your policy says
that the exchange rate can go up and
down you need to have market signals
determining whether it's going up for
damn good topic and that's it that's a
serious conversation because it has to
do with the competitiveness of us goods
in China mr. secretary I suspect another
topic russia plans to turn to china for
money or ask Janet for money investments
to compensate for what they're losing
with the sanctions from the US and the
EU are you going to pressure urge your
your Chinese counterparts not to go
along yeah we talked about a wide range
of topics when we meet I'm going to
bring the topics that are central to the
u.s. agenda and they will raise topics
of concern to them I think that you know
this was certainly being essential to us
wouldn't if they're going to compensate
for the loss of money in Russia because
of the we've been making the case
consistently wherever we go that that is
acceptable for Russia to violate
Ukraine's sovereignty and that when we
take actions and other countries in the
world take action it is important for
there not to be back fill and we would
not be happy then that the Chinese word
well it is an argument I make wherever I
go and you'll make it envisioned well
you know we're going to talk about a
whole range topics how about let's talk
about Putin the Ukraine why not impose
tougher sectoral sanctions now rather
than waiting if so would they apply to a
wide swath of financial and energy
industries or be more targeted specific
that the steps we've taken with regard
to Russia have been very carefully
determined and they've been quite
effective we have acted to target people
in the Russian government senior
executive CEOs who run some of the
largest manufacturing firms in Russia
who are very close to the government and
we have sanctioned the bank making it
clear that we are prepared to go farther
down this path should we need to